The partners at TouchTen
we are brothers that really enjoy
games ever since we were young.
And so naturally
when we come form a company,
we want to work on something we really enjoy
and that is mobile games.
Mobile games is a
global competitive market.
But coming back to the local market,
we see strong support from the
Indonesian and Southeast Asian
gamers towards local content.
The strength that we know we have is that
we are local, we are here,
we speak the language
and we know the culture.
The games that we make
have a lot of things in common
which is food.
And this is a really good inspiration
to make this game, Warung Chain.
Part of the insight
that we also get is that
a lot of foodies, people who like food,
also like to be able to own a shop.
Our game gives that kind of simulation
where you own and manage a restaurant.
Now for Warung Chain
close to 3 million people
download the game.
What Google Play has allowed us to do
is to very easily launch our games
bring it to the gamers that like it
to gain insights and improvements
on the game as a result.
For one of our games called Dessert Chain
we just did AB testing for the app icon.
More than 60% of our local users
prefer character icon to food icon.
That’s super awesome feedback for us.
We were very proud to submit Warung Chain
in Indonesia Game contest
the very first local
game competition provided by Google.
We got really really hyped
when the Google Play team said
that Warung Chain is the winner.
This is home to many
vibrant local developers
as well as the young
population that we have
which I think will be a
market not to be ignored.
In the same way that we try to
understand our local audience
we want to bring this
to the global audience
and to bring meaningful content to them.
This goes in line with our
company name Touch Ten
is to touch the sky
and that’s our aim.
We are very proud
to be made in Indonesia
and we want to put
Indonesia in the map
a game creator,
not just as a game consumer.